okay texas counties overwhelmed as you
know by as many as 30 000 illegal
immigrants in just the past few weeks
suing the biden administration now over
its handling of the border crisis this
comes as panamanian officials apparently
warn of a larger caravan of migrants
possibly up to 60 000 people
heading to the united states from there
while expressing concern the
administration can't handle it telling
axios quote the white house seemed
caught off guard and they shouldn't have
been because they got a warning months
ago what who is anybody working there
fox news contributor lara trump joins us
now to react it's unbelievable i did not
think that the uh the panama who's an
ally of ours would have trouble getting
through to the president
yeah well it seems rather purposeful
doesn't it brian that this is all
happening i mean and what an
embarrassment this is yet another world
leader who is calling out the country
calling out the united states of america
and the biden administration saying
you guys better pay attention to this
because you are not doing your job
remember when our borders are kamala
harris went down to guatemala and the
guatemalan president embarrassed her by
saying you guys send bad messaging and
you're telling people to come up through
you know our countries and come to the
united states of america so i mean it's
crazy that you're right that panama
couldn't warn the united states but
brian they know it's happening and at a
certain point people have to ask
themselves is this just part of the
democrat plan i think we have to keep
talking about that because this sort of
thing cannot be an accident when you do
not secure your southern border when you
do not follow the laws of the land which
joe biden is not doing i mean it's got
to be purposeful
well and and laura this week you know
they were breaking ground for the barack
obama presidential library abc sat down
with former president barack obama and
he talked he was asked about what's
going on on our southern border with the
wide open borders and he said
uh it's unsustainable but they did not
run that particular clip on television
it was hidden on the internet we dug it
up here's the former president watch
this
we're a nation state we have borders the
idea that we can just have open borders
is something that
i think
as a practical matter is is
unsustainable and and laura that's the
headline from the interview and they
didn't play it
yeah i mean again
these things are not accents this is the
same media that this is what they did
throughout the entirety of the trump
administration throughout the campaign
and 2020 throughout the campaign quite
frankly in 2016 i mean it's lying by
omission and it doesn't take a rocking
scientist steve to figure out that if
you do not have borders you don't have a
country if you can't prevent people from
just free-flowing into your country then
the sovereignty of your country is
totally gone but i mean i guess the goal
is to you know prop up the democrats and
make sure that that their talking points
are out there and they don't want people
to hear that
barack obama is right we have to have
borders and we have to enforce the laws
at our borders and unfortunately it is
not being done right now it is
incredibly detrimental to the united
states the ap call they want
confirmation you just said barack obama
was right right
maybe the one time that i'm going to
agree with him yes he's correct in this
matter all right lara trump thanks so
much